Ngo năm đường chính buồn bộ ý tế cùng các bộ ngành tập trung tháo gớ khó khăn
Bình viện bách mai cơ sở những bình chính thức đi vào hòa đồng
Đây là công trình ý tế trong biệm của Cúc ra
Lược xây dựng với Kymô một nghìn dường bài
Bởi bám bị bài khoa phòng và hơn mềm một in giang mục
Thật chuyên môn, công môn, in ba trăm cám mổ, nhìn vì lý tế rầu kinh nghiệm
Được luôn chuyện từ cơ sở mổ
Bình viện bách mai cơ sở những bình được bản hành theo mô hình một bình viện bách mai một chuyện trân lợ
Thà nó tàn bộ hệ thống quản chi của chính chuyên môn
Cứ chuyển trân lợ, công mề thông tin và hỏng động khám trân bệm được tổ trước thống nhất với bình viện bách mai tả hanoi
Bình khám và điều chỉ tại cơ sở những bình sẽ được tiếp cận cùng hệ thống chuyên gia đồng ngành
Cung quyết chính kiết thỏa, công têu chuyển trân lợ và cùng chức lý lấy người bệnh làm chúng tâm
Đổi ngữ giao sư, ngó giao sư, tiền sĩ, bác sĩ đồng ngành
Thứ bánh viện bách mai hà nội sẽ chức tiếp thăm gia khám bệm, điều chỉ khôi trần
Nào tạo và chuyển rào kiết thật tả n cơ sở những bình và đảm chất lựa chuyển môn đồng nhất trong bản hiệm thống
Phát biểu tại buổi lẽ, có thụ bướng chính phủ ngệm văn tháng khẳng đề
Bây giờ sự kiển coi nghĩa đặc biệt, không chỉ đánh giấu bức phát triển của ngành y tế
Mà còn thế hiện quyết tâm của đảng nhận nước chính phủ trong việc hiện thử khóa trù chương
Quết tâm viện đầu tư của nhận nước, cho thành công trình thất thật phục vụ người dân
Hó tuếng yêu cầu bình viện tiếp tục hoàn thiển chính phát triển ở dụng khó công nghệ
Chuyển rào kiết thật, đào tạo, bây giờ bình viện trường thành bình viện tuyên quyết
Nön cào chăm sóc sức khỏe cho nhận dân, với hệ thống trang thích bị hiện đại
Cung yêu chuyên khoá mối nhỏ, bình viện bánh mai cơ sở những bình được ký vọng
Chở thành chung tâm vi tế chuyển sâu của khu vực, mở rộn có hội tiếp cận dịch quyết tế trước lượng cao
Cho hàng chiều người dân khu vực năm đồng bằng xung hồng và bắt xung bộ
Cũng trong sang này, bình viện tạch mai cùng tổng tý đường sắp viện năm đã khai chương đoàn tạo đưa cán bộ
Y bác xí của bình viện tạch mai tới lòng việc dưới 2 kư dựa hành hội và ninh bình
Từ thứ 2 đến thứ 6 hành tuần, nhằm bảo đam, an tuàn và thần tiện cho đổi mũ cán bộ
Y bác xí y lòng việc tạch đây